[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 78
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
rugby une victoire de plus pour le Sky
en promotion d'honneur les bleus et
verts ont remporté ce dimanche à
domicile leur 13e victoire de la saison
en 13 matchs disputés les éin ont battu
fontonésienne sur le score de 66 à 12
les détails dans ce magazine voil la
présentation des concurrents du prochain
vend des globes était organisé ce
mercredi à Paris ils seront 27 skippers
à s'élancer des Sables d'Olonne le 6
novembre prochain parmi eux deux
versaillais Éric Béon et tangy de
laamote gymnastique le championnat
régional est programmé ce weekend au
Palais des Sports d'élancour les favoris
de la compétition seront une nouvelle
fois les athlètes du club de gymnastique
des gymnastique d'lancour morpa nous les
recevons dans cette émission et puis
l'essentiel de l'actualité sportive du
département nous parlerons NOTAM du 15e
tournoi international de badminton qui
s'est tenu ce weekend à 5S en
yeline les semaines se suivent et se
ressent pour le Sky rugby les hommes de
Thomas paayen se sont très facilement
imposés face à fontonésienne sur le
score de 66 à 12 un résultat qui leur
permet d'accentuer leur avant sur le
deuxè clairement Clermont Romin rpini
pour le
montage une victoire de plus pour le SK
rugby en promotion d'honneur les bleus
et verts ont remporté ce dimanche à
domicile leur 13e victoire de la saison
en 13 matchs disputés les Invincibles
ont écraser fontonésienne 66 à 12 dans
un nouveau festival offensif on a fait
une bonne entame on a pris le score tout
de suite après
oui on a mis en place notre jeu un petit
relâchement début deuxème mi-temps et
après c'est bien terminé aujourd'hui
très satisfait des joueurs sur la
pration sur la volonté de jouer à la
fois devant derrière d'alterner le jeu
donc par rapport à ça satisfait c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui par rapport au
weekend précédent on a pu voir toute
l'étendue de de notre jeu au classement
le Sky rugby réalise la bonne opération
de cette 13e journée avec sa victoire
combinée à la défaite du 2e clairement
sur le terrain de ronéen les ilinois
comptent désormais 9 points d'avant sur
leur dauphin la monté l'objectif fixé en
début de saison est donc plus que jamais
réalisable l'objectif fixé c'est la
victoire dans chaque match pour assurer
le la montée en en honneur qui est très
difficile parce qu'il y a que deux clubs
en île-de-fance qui montent on est en L
comme plein d'autres clubs pour
l'instant on est sur notre fil on est
bien on est bien par rapport à ce qu'on
s'était fixé en début d'année mais on a
pas droit à l'erreur prochain match pour
le Sky rugby le dimanche 14 février sur
le terrain du 2e Clermont pour le choc
de cette 14e journée une équipe que les
iinois avaient dominé 27 à 20 en
novembre
dernier après le rugby on prend le large
coup de projecteur sur le vent des
globes
2016 nous sommes avec erriic bon le
skipper versaillais alors éic nous
allons tout d'abord parler de la Transat
Jacques Vabre ça s'est plutôt bien passé
même très bien passé pour vous pour une
première participation ouais ça s super
bien passé on a on est arrivé 7e au
Brésil sur un plateau de 20 bateaux avec
bah les meilleurs de du plateau imoka
donc on était vraiment très content très
fier il y a eu des conditions difficiles
donc il y a beaucoup de bateaux qui on
abandonné mais on a surtout super bien
fonctionné avec mon coskiper Sam goodch
on a vécu une aventure vraiment
extraordinaire tous les deuxéit votre
première participation pas trop
préhenstion au départ c'est notre
première participation à tous les deux
ça m moi et bah oui bien sûr il y avait
de l'appréhension maintenant pas trop il
y avait on va dire suffisamment
d'appréhension pour être concentré et
pas faire trop de bêtises au début
surtout parce que c'est c'est au début
qu' a eu du mauvais temps vous attendiez
à atteindre cette 7e place vous y
attendiez ù c'est un petit peu les les
abandons qui ont fait que finalement
vous avez terminé 7e bah on s'attendait
absolument pas à faire 7e ça c'est sûr
c'est sûr que les abandons nous ontcoup
beaucoup aidé mais on était quand même
dans le coup au départ on a bien navigué
on a eu de la chance aussi il en faut
mais surtout on a naviguer tous les deux
de façon harmonieuse parce qu'on a
beaucoup travaillé notre collaboration
et en fait on a pu on a beaucoup investi
dans le fait de bah de pouvoir nous dire
nos nos doutes nos faiblesses en même
temps que nos forces et ce qui fait que
notre duo a super bien fonctionn et
c'est tout le thème de comme un seul
homme c'est comment on arrive avec une
équipe qui est pas forcément bonne sur
le papier à faire des choses assez
exceptionnelles et c'est toute la magie
de la diversité parce qu'on était tous
les deux très différents et c'est cette
singularité en fait qui a fait notre
performance et qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé à vous concourir dans la Transat
JAV et bientôt le vent des globes
qu'est-ce qui vous pousse à participer à
ces compétitions mythiques on peut le
dire on va dire que c'est le goût du
défi d'abord et aussi c'est ça fait
partie d'une démarche que j'ai amorcé il
y a une quinzaine d'années qui est une
réflexion sur la diversité humaine euh
savoir en quoi la diversité peut
apporter de la de la richesse on dit
souvent que la diversité c'est une
richesse c'est pas vrai la diversité
c'est souvent d'abord des difficultés
quand on est différent quand on se
croise c'est difficile parce qu'on a pas
les mêmes façons de faire on n pas les
même façon de vivre les mêmes façons de
penser mais si on a envie de travailler
ensemble et si on a on partage le
fondamental on arrive à faire de très
très grandes choses on arrive surtout à
faire des choses nouvelles parce qu'on
est différent et donc c'est en même
temps le goût du défi moi je suis
passionné de merde passionné de de de
Course au Large donc je suis en train de
réaliser un de mes rêves et en même
temps je porte une conviction qui qui me
porte et qui me dépasse en fait c'est un
vrai rêve mais un rêve devenu réalité
finalement bah ouais ouais ouais c'est
un rêve devenu réalité surtout avec les
14 mcien qui nous accompagne il y a
80000 collaborateurs qui participent à
cette aventure là donc c'est une totale
réalité le budget est quasiment bouclé
on attend qu' 15e mesenes pour surtout
pour fininer l'aspect communication mais
on est là on est prêt on a déjà fait une
belle course on a encore plein de choses
à faire moi j'ai tout un aspect qui est
le solitaire à vraiment découvrir sur ce
bateaul donc c'est un gros dossier à à
mettre en place mais j'adore ça je me
fais plaisir et je suis très confiant
pour la suite quoi voilà et donc dans
quelques mois vous allez participer au
vent des globes une course mythique une
course que vous voulez terminer bien sûr
bien sûr le bah déjà la première
victoire c'est des yett donc ça c'est
àquis
euh après il peut tout arriver mais
àquis après la bouclé moi c'est vraiment
mon objectif je suis un amateur je vais
pas gagner le vent des globes je vais
essayer de faire la plus belle course
que je peux je vais d'abord me faire
plaisir et bien sûr boucler ramener mon
bateau au sable de lun ça ça pourrait
être vraiment la grande aventure je vais
avoir 40 ans et en fait c'est le cadeau
que je me fais pour mes 40 ans et je
veux boucler ouis et la course se fait
en solitaire tout à fait en solitaire
c'est 3 mois de solitaire 3 mois où on
ben on se retrouve tout seul
à à régler nos propres problèmes à
régler notre propre course on est
responsable de tout il y a personne
derrière qui peut rattraper une bêtise
qu'on fait c'est à nous de veiller sur
notre sécurité à veiller à la météo donc
c'est quelque chose qui nous grandit
aussi énormément c'est une course pour
apprendre à se connaître moi j'ai un un
objectif personnel c'est de de me
trouver en harmonie avec la mer et mon
bateau fermer un trio assez magique
c'est ce que je cherche il n'y a pas de
trop d'appréhension justement il n'y a
pas trop d'appréhension sur le fait de
partir seul comme ça en pleine mer il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas cette
appréhension là et c'est évident qu'il y
a de l'appréhension il y a de la peur
mais c'est pas une peur paralysante
c'est une peur qui donne envie de se
concentrer de qui envie de se dépasser
et et en fait c'est une peur qui est
constructive mais je je vous mentirai
c'est en vous disant que je ressens rien
c'est j'ai me retrouvver sur un bateau
de 18 m tout seul moi qui est quasiment
jamais fait de de solitaire donc oui
j'appréhende et en même temps je suis
très excité j'en ai très envie ça en
fait c'est un package voilà il y a il y
a tout là-dedans et c'est ce qui fait la
beauté de la course c'est ce qui fait la
beauté aussi de cet engagement et votre
famille en pense quoi de de ce départ ah
bah ils sont tous derrière moi ma
famille je sais que ça ça leur fait peur
aussi parce que bah c'est l'inconnu nous
c'est assez simple en fait on est en mer
donc on règle les problèmes un à un on
est très occupé mais eux restent à terre
et c'est vrai que l'imagination court
c'est ce qui fait aussi le myth de cette
course c'est que on s'imagine toujours
ce que qui est en train de vivre le
skipper tout seul sur son bateau et donc
ils me soutiennent à fond ils sont à
fond dernière moi et puis ils ont une
appréhension on est tous excités et et
un peu tendu aussi ouais aujourd'hui on
est à la conférence de presse du vent
desgobes il y a des grands skipppers qui
étaient là aujourd'hui Vincent Riou
Tangui de Lamotte ça vous inspire quoi
bah déjà je suis dans mes petits
souliers parce que c'est vrai que je
suis avec tous les les skippers qui qui
me font
rêver les skipers dont je lis les
exploits dans dans les magazines dans
les bouquins sur les sites internet donc
je suis hyper heureux c'est un peu comme
si j'étais un fan de foot et que je
participais à à la conférence de presse
du Mondial quoi c'est exactement la même
chose donc je suis hyper fier je suis
dans mes petits souliers et puis j'ai
envie de respecter cette course j'ai
envie de faire vraiment de mon mieux
pour respecter les coureurs et la course
donc je devrais me donner encore plus de
mal et du mal on s'en donne parce qu'on
bosse avec toute l'équipe que ça soit
l'équipe de la communication et l'équipe
technique on bosse comme des fous pour
être prêts et quel serait votre plus
grand rêve sur ce des globes mon plus
grand rêve battre les skippers qui
étaient présents aujourd'hui non non
c'est c'est c'est pas mon grand rêve ça
serait extraordinaire et mais bon on va
voir on on a déjà battu quelquesuns sur
la jacvab alors pourquoi pas mais c'est
pas mon plus grand rêve mon plus grand
rêve c'est de revivre un quelque chose
que j'avais déjà vécu sur mon premier
tour du monde sur un tout petit bateau
de 8 m un moment dans le le grand sud
dans l'océan australe où je me suis
tellement senti bien que je m'étais dit
à cette époque là si quelqu'un arrive
débarque sur le bateau et me propose les
plus grandes richesses de la planète le
maximum d'argent qui est sur la planète
pour me prendre ma place je lui diraai
non parce que je jamais je donnerai la
place la chose que je vis en ce moment
c'est trop beau et c'est ce genre de
bonheur absolu qu'on a en mer et je
pense que ça va être décuplé ça va être
un million de fois ça pendant le vent
des globes merci beaucoup Éric Bellon
merci un autre versiller accompagnera
Eric Béon sur sur ce tour du monde en
solitaire sans escale et sans assistance
son nom t gu de la mote le skiper
yvelinois participera pour la deuxième
fois à la compétition en 2013
l'ivelinois avait terminé à la 10e place
il espère évidemment faire mieux on
l'écoute le navigateur était au micro de
Fanny à
Bourdillon comme la dernière fois ça
sera de finir la course pu a l'objectif
sportif qui serait de faire le tour du
monde en en 80 jours avec ce bateau et
avec le temps de préparation que j'ai eu
c'est c'est quelque chose de possible
c'est c'est un objectif réaliste qui est
élevé mais réaliste les deux versaill
prendront le large le 6 novembre
prochain prochain des Sables d'Olonne
les skippers Vinois succéderont
peut-être à François gabar vainqueur de
l'épreuve en 2013 en 78 jours après la
voile on passe maintenant à la
gymnastique le championnat régional de
gymnastique est programmé sous weekend
au Palais des Sports d'éencour les
favoris de la compétition seront une
nouvelle fois les athlètes du club de
gymnastique d'éencour morpa pour nous
parler de cette compétition nous
recevons sur ce plateau l'entraîneur du
GEM Émilie Roy Marline MAE gymnaste
champion de France en 2015 audre audre
fatnaass pardon excusez-moi membre du
comité directeur et Zell le riche
gymnaste championne de France 2015
bonsoir alors ce ce championnat régional
on peut dire que c'est un gros
rendez-vous pour le club et pour même
tous les gymnastes en général ili c'est
un gros rendez-vous à deux niveaux d'une
part sur l'aspect de l'organisation
parce que ça nécessite tout le transport
du matériel une grosse équipe de
bénévoles donc sur sur le matériel sur
l'accueil des gymnastes sur la buvette
sur les différents stands qui seront
organisés et puis bah le deuxième niveau
c'est le niveau compétitif où c'est on
va dire le premier championnat un petit
peu important de la saison et et les
gymnaste et nous les entraîneurs on
prépare ça avec avec beaucoup de sérieux
audreé pourquoiir avoir décidé de
l'organiser au Palais des Sports dlon
courours pour chaque club se doit de
d'organiser une à deux compétitions dans
l'année euh et puis c'est un lieu qui
s'y prête on a beaucoup de tribunes la
salle est quand même assez volumineuse
et on a la la chance de travailler avec
la mairie de d'élancour et de
morpa qui sont très heureux à chaque
fois de de nous offrir leurs locaux euh
donc donc voilà on est content à chaque
fois d'organiser ce genre de d'événement
en fait au sein du club et il devrait
avoir combien de gymnastes pour la
compétition alors on attend à peu près
300 gymnastes euh et entre 1500 et
2000 supporters et du coup vous avez mis
combien de temps pour organiser ce ce ce
ce rassemblement ce rendez-vous alors
euh la décision on va dire s faite début
septembre donc on s'y prépare petit à
petit mais c'est vrai qu'il faut des
semaines et des semaines en amont on a
beaucoup de choses à gérer euh tout un
travail en amont avec la mairie euh avec
le comité régional aussi de
l'île-defance ouest et puis bien sûr
faire appel à différentes personnes du
club les
bénévoles qui sont nombreux et on les
remercie encore parce que sans eux bah
il se passerait pas grand-chose pour ce
genre de manifestation donc voilà comme
l'a dit très bien
Émilie on a différents pôles à à
organiser que ça soit bah le la buvette
l'équipement sportif les les juges donc
voilà et le niveau sera bon sur cette
compétition il y aura des des athlètes
de haut niveau euh oui alors on il
commence à y avoir des des des athlètes
de de de très bon niveau à cette étape
régionale il y a il y a pas mal de clubs
qui travaillent très bien et puis sur le
dernier tour samedi
soir la il y aura des gymnastes des
clubs et aussi notre équipe du Top 12
qui seront en test un test en vue de
préparer les
échéances qui Arve prochainement
c'est-à-dire la qualification pour les
championnats de France pour les gymnases
des autres clubs et puis ben le Top 12
pour notre équipe féminine qui s'est
qualifié l'année dernière
Marline le club dancour morpa sera
encore un épouvantail dans cette
compétition vu que vous que vous vous
gagnez toujours les compétitions et
cetera en ce moment est-ce que est-ce
que ça enfin le club sera encore
l'épouventail de cette compétition non
on peut pas dire ça mais on après on
fait du mieux qu'on peut on essaie de
représenter au mieux le club après il y
a très bon club dans toute la région
donc la compétition reste la compétition
et ça sera au meilleur qui gagnera ce
jour-ci et qu'est sont vos principaux
concurrents sur la compétition il y a il
y a a il y a plein de clubs qui
travaillent très
bien par exemple bah il y a sur le
département il y a les clubs de Limet de
Guill encour qui présentent des gymnases
de qualité
le club de clamar le club d'herblé qui
ont des des des jolies
gymnastes donc on sait que dès lors que
nos gymnastes vont être contre les
gymnastes de ce club là et ben c'est le
jeu de la concurrence et
puis voilà que la meilleure gagne une
fois de plus nous au club on a pour
habitude de de concentrer les gymnases
sur leurs propres performan sur les
objectifs techniques qu'on qu'on leur
fixe et surtout de leur dire que il faut
pas se concentrer sur les autres que
après c'est le sport et qu'on souhaite
de toute façon à la meilleure le jour J
de remporter la médaille et vous vous
êtes entraîné durement pour cette
compétition alors la période elle est un
petit peu difficile parce que on est en
plein hiver et que on sent que les les
jeunes filles sont fatiguées les
organismes sont fatigués donc pour
éviter des blessur ou une saturation on
essaie de préparer avec rigueur cette
compétition qui commence à être
importante mais on ménage encore un
petit peu les athlètes parce que le le
pic de la saison il est pas encore là il
sera au top 12 pour nos nos plus âgés et
puis au moment des championnats de zone
au mois d'avril pour les plus jeunes
donc voilà de la rigueur du sérieux de
l'implication mais on on les préserve
encore donc là vous serez à la 3è
compétition de l'année voilà vous êtes
encore en rodage ça va jouer sur la
performance et c'est possible parce que
zéie pourra en parler mieux que moi tout
à l'heure mais on teste encore des
nouveaux éléments on comme justement on
ne souhaite pas trop tirer sur les
organismes on n' pas encore un niveau de
répétition qui est suffisant pour
que l'élément passe avec certitude mais
il faut aussi s'habituer à le présenter
dans le contexte compétitif donc et ben
on le teste et on sait que ça peut
passer comme ne pas passer donc oui
c'est du rodage on lui on leur souhaite
hein de de réussir bien évidemment mais
on sait qu'on en est pas encore au stade
où tout est bien calé voilà ça c'est
pour l'échéance supplémentaire donc vous
en parliez a quelques instants zé euh
toi tu as quelques objectifs hein sur
ces championnats quels sont tes
objectifs bah me qualifier pour les
championnats de France et aller sur le
podium en individuel et en équipe euh
dans la aller dans l'AdN1 et donc pas
trop de pression sur ce ce rendez-vous
si un petit peu parce que j'ai des
nouveaux éléments au sol et au bar et
j'ai envie de les réussir et vous pensez
qu'elle peut atteindre ses objectifs
Émilie oui oui tout à fait euh elle
travaille pour en tout cas donc donc on
lui on lui souhaite que vu le la somme
de travail qu'elle fournit à
l'entraînement elle mérite effectivement
de réussir mais après la compétition
c'est la compétition avec avec sa sa
petite somme de hasard ça dépend de
comment elle va elle va gérer cette
pression zée c'est peut-être la future
pépite de du GEM elle fait effectivement
partie avec d'autres d'autres copines
des petites pépites de l'avenir du club
voilà on elle et nous on travaille avec
sérieux et on est très heureux d'avoir
des petites filles comme elles au sein
de notre association il y aura également
vous Marline vous qui allez participer
du coup à la compétition vous pareil
vous serez peut-être en période un petit
peu de de rodage en vue du Top 12 oui
tout à fait cette
compétition reste un test déjà
préparatoire pour la compétition du Top
12 après même si ça reste une échéance
pour moi puisque je je reste en
compétition pour éventuellement
aller concourir au championnat de France
aussi en fin d'année donc donc voilà
c'est ça reste une échéance quand même
avec de l'importance puisque ça sera la
dernière compétition avant vraiment le
top 12 c'est une grosse échéance pour
nous et du coup vos objectifs sont assez
élevés sur cette compétition ou ou vous
dites voilà je vais essayer de faire du
mieux possible tout à fait je vais
essayer de faire du mieux possible je
vais essayer de rentrer mes nouveaux
éléments
que ça soit au bar que ça soit en poutre
au sol j'en ai pas mal à mettre cette
année ça sera voilà vraiment je vais
essayer de faire ça au mieux pour me
rassurer pour pour le Top 12
prochainement vous êtes d'accord ce
qu'elle dit Marline est en rodage
actuellement oui voilà tout à fait elle
a beaucoup travaillé depuis le début de
l'année pour préparer ses nouveaux ses
nouveaux éléments ils sont prêts à être
à être mis présentés en compéti i
maintenant cette somme d'éléments mis
bout à bout dans le contexte de la
compétition bah ça ça va être plus
compliqué et et ça va être à elle de le
de de de le gérer avec sérénité c'est
pour ça qu'on met pas de pression sur
les résultats que c'est plutôt des
objectifs techniques et puis on sera
prêt enfin elle sera prête dans 6
semaines après pour les présenter sur le
Top 12 mais avec avec plus d'assurance
donc le Top 12 ça sera la à côté de la
roche
c'est ça le 19 mars si je me trompe pas
et du coup votre objectif c'est celui-là
c'est c'est l'objectif de VO c'est c'est
la grosse échéance de la saison en
équipe et donc voilà on va essayer de
faire du mieux qu'on pourra pour cette
date là et vous visez combien de de
titres ce weekend vous avez un un
chiffre un pronostic peut-être alors
honnêtement j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
compté je pourrais pas vous vous dire
alors on va pas effectivement bah s'il y
a plein de titres on sera super super
content en tant qu'entraîneur je seraai
super contente pour les gymnastes qui
s'entraînent tous les jours parce que
elles sont très investies elles passent
beaucoup d'heur dans la salle elles
répondent à nos exigences et elle mérit
d'avoir une récompense même si elle rate
un peu pendant la compétition au regard
du travail qu'elle fournissent à
l'entraînement elle mérite d'avoir une
récompense donc je leur souhaite à
toutes d'avoir d'avoir des médailles
mais honnêtement je peux pas vous
annoncer de chiffre j'ai pas j'ai pas
j'ai pas compter et donc zé est obligé
de gagner ah bah maintenant qu'on l'a
dit en plateau
voilàigé dernière question tout le monde
peut peut venir assister à la
compétition oui donc les portes sont
ouvertes euh souvent bien évidemment on
a les parents et les grands-parents bah
qui viennent supporter leur temps de
récher et puis parfois on a aussi les
les amis des uns et des autres
et et ça nous arrive aussi qu'il a des
personnes qui ne connaissent peu ou
presque pas la gymnastique et qui ont
été influencé par par par des personnes
qui sont au club et qui viennent quand
même qui regardent et qui sont euh
merveilleusement on va dire fascinés par
ce qui se passe quoi merci à toutes les
cas d'être passé sur ce plateau bon
courage donc pour cette compétition
donnera tous les résultats lundi
prochain dans le 78 sport on passe
maintenant au
badminton le 15e tournoi international
de double é organisé ce weekend par
l'équipe de volant d'lancour plus de 350
badistes ont participé à la compétition
le dimanche des doubles mixtes se sont
affrontés pour emporter la victoire
Patrick Jacques de dickmud pour les
images c'est désormais une tradition
pour la 15e année consécuti le tournoi
international de double était organisé
ce weekend au Palais des Sports
d'élancour la compétition a réuni plus
de 350 badistes venu principalement de
la région parisienne objectif de chaque
concurrent remporter la victoire chaque
joueur évidemment a des prend des points
pour ses classements personnels et puis
il y a il y a un
lot qui faire au vainqueur de de chaque
catégorie et au finalistes après les
doubles dames et hommes le samedi place
au double mixte le dimanche les
placements et les techniques pour
déborder les adversaires sont évidemment
différentes dans le mix la fille elle
est beaucoup plus sur l'avant beaucoup
plus rapprochée du filet par rapport au
garçon le garçon a un peu une image de
de frappe il est un peu derrière pour
frapper derrière sur les smatch comme ça
et les fill beaucoup plus techniquement
pour poser le jeu autre facteur à gérer
pour les duos pendant la compétition
l'esprit d'équipe une symbiose parfaite
est indispensable pour remporter la
victoire on a tous les deux fait des
bons coups tous les deux fait des fautes
donc c partagé voilà la défaite partagée
comme la victoire parmi les principaux
résultats hisistoire de ha de LAAC et
Tibo Ruols du club de fontely le Fury se
sont imposés dans la catégorie P2 P3 et
Justine ovin et Sébastien curlier d lanc
ont remporté la finale dans la catégorie
R4
R5
on commence cette rubrique résultat par
du football américain les Templiers d'
lancour ont repris le chemin de la
compétition ce weekend un retour gagnant
les élan courtois se sont imposés 18 à 6
contre les gladiateurs de la queue enri
le Running Back Alexander tassong a
marqué un touchdown dès le coup de pied
d'engagement avec un retour de plus de
80 yardes Cyril Gérard et Rod Surpin ont
ensuite corsé l'addition les gladateurs
ont ensuite réduit l'écart en fin de
match au classement les Templiers sont
premiers du championnat dès la première
journée ils se déplaceront sur le
terrain des flash de la cour neuve le
weekend prochain les Templiers se sont
retrouvés hier soir à minuit au Tomy
diners des clés sous- bois pour regarder
la finale du Super B entre les Broncos
de Denver et les Carolina Panters ils
étaient près d'une cinquantaine dont les
Ch leaders du club a regardé la finale
du championnat américain jusqu'à 5h du
matin je vous rappelle que le match
s'est soldé par la victoire des Broncos
24 à 10 on reste dans le sport américain
en basket trappe s'est imposé ce weekend
à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
bonconeil lors de la 15e journée du
championnat de National 3 score finale
53 à à 46 une victoire acquise grâce à
une grosse défense des joueurs de
mostafha et lafidi au classement trappe
grapill dépl les ibinois sont désormais
6e en embuscade à seulement un petit
point du podium en bal féminin rien ne
va plus pour montiny bretonau en
National 1 les inimontines se sont
inclinés 21 à 19 à domicile contre Nant
Loire Atlantique une lourde défaite de
lourde de conséquence au classement
Montini est toujours bon dernier du
championnat avec un bilan de 10 défaites
unnul et seulement deux victoires depuis
le début de la saison on prend à présent
la direction de bois d'Arc la 14e
édition de la course d'orientation au
castor s'est déroulée ce dimanche dans
la commune autour du stade de
Jean-Moulin plusieurs parcours étaient
au programme dont à 18 km en pleine
nature cette année 615 courageux ont
participé à l'événement l'organisatrice
Sandrine Tesson était au micro de
Patrick Jacques de
dix les participants ont une carte entre
les mains avec un parcours dessiné et le
but est donc de prendre les postes dans
l'ordre indiqué en avec un doigt
électronique en bipant directement sur
le boîtier il y a différents circuits
effectivement des circuits chronométrés
et des circuits non chronométrés et sur
les concernant les circuits chronométrés
vous avez différentes distances aussi en
fonction de la difficulté de la longueur
que le coureur veut veut accomplir un
mot de cyclisme sur piste à présent la
coupe d'hiver d'île-defance était
programmée ce samedi au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Yveline la
compétition recessenscé près de 150
engagés sur la journée venant
principalement d'Île-de- France des
têtes d'affiche comme Laor Berton et la
FARG ont participé à l'événement au
niveau des épreuves les coureurs se sont
affrontés sur le scratch et l'Omnium on
écoute Jérémy Fromonteil l'organisateur
de
l'événement c'est une compétition qui
est
a qui est à destination des coururs
amateurs en en priorité des coureurs
jeunes on a ici toutes les catégories
aujourd'hui donc des jeunes à partir de
12 ans les minimes les cadets au-dessus
les juniors et les élites qui sont là en
train de de concourir et les coureurs
loisir qui ont concouru et continu à
concourir au long de la au long de la
journée de la boxe pour terminer le
Boxing Club de laav a organisé le
championnat régional d'Île-deFrance
cadet et cadette ce weekend le club
local a réussi à obtenir quatre titres
au niveau régional Sacha Martinovic déjà
champion en 2015 et devenu champion
d'île-de-fance il est donc qualifié pour
le championnat interrégional Jordan
dwick est lui devenu champion
île-de-fance dans la catégorie des moins
de 86 kg en étant grippé yusri berniu et
Yayou Shara ont eux perdu la en finale
et deviennent donc vice-champion
régional c'est c'est la fin de ce C
suite sport merci de l'avoir suivi très
belle soirée sur TVfil
[Musique]